what is your opinion on why we have
inflation right now because you were the
free cash guy and one of the biggest
questions we got all the time was won't
this cause massive inflation the main
reason we have an inflation is that you
have more demand and supply uh just like
people want stuff there's not enough
stuff
and so the price are going up i'll give
you an example i went to buy a bike
for
um my older son and they were like hey
we get we have no new bikes and i was
like interesting
and then to the extent they had any
bikes the bikes were expensive
you know i mean so then
um so you play that out across different
categories and so you have high
inflation now the the simple
relationship people are putting out
there is like oh you've like put more
money in the system so prices went up
it's like let's imagine that we had not
put more money in the system
is there a bike in that bike shop
waiting for me
no no you know
it didn't solve that problem
you know so so that so that's what's
going on in different areas of the
economy
and
blaming it on quote-unquote you know
printing more money
is an oversimplification
the argument i make is look we we
printed 2.2 trillion dollars with the
cares act but it didn't go to people or
families it went to banks and airlines
and
now and the pipes
uh and so you can say it's like oh stop
printing money it's causing inflation
it's like
like it's a little bit more complicated
than all that
um but i will say that if you wanted to
alleviate the misery caused by inflation
putting money into people's hands would
be the way to go and they're making that
argument a little bit with buildback
better they're like oh it's going to
help you with child care it's going to
help you with this going to help you
with that so it's a tough spot but you
can see the partisan communication
around inflation which by the way
now my sense is that uh it is
serious it's painful it's at a level now
where it's hurting people who have
the least the most
[Music]
[Music]
this week on the podcast first happy
thanksgiving zach and i are going to
talk about what we've been enjoying in
terms of the streaming content universe
we are also going to talk about some uh
tough stuff in the written house verdict
what's going on with the biden
administration and more
happy thanksgiving zach so much to be
grateful for happy turkey day man
yes what uh what are your plans your new
paltz okay
my
famous
the infamous house
but yes i will be there
and
and so i thought we'd open with
something really really practical and so
i call
my brother-in-law the content truffle
pig which is that he always finds like
yeah like interesting things to watch
in the streaming universe okay so we're
gonna open up with some content
recommendations
for the people at home when what's going
to happen is they're going to eat their
thanksgiving meal they're going to watch
the bills win hopefully they're going to
wake up or maybe they'll stay up that
night they'll wake up the next day
they'll have a bit of time and then
they'll be looking for something to
watch
so what do we have to recommend to the
people as to what they can see that will
make them happy okay let's open up with
that netflix movie they probably already
have watched red notice with the rock
gallagher i like dan reynolds it's like
lame but it's good you know what i'm
saying it's like an action movie
have you seen it i don't i didn't see
yeah so you can wear notes on this all
right so this will be good because then
everyone can judge whether they agree
more with me or zac like it was a
confection is the word i'd give it was
very pretty um there wasn't much
suspense to it it was mildly enjoyable
you know it was vastly superior to red
notice in my opinion
it was uh if you haven't seen it on
amazon and these two movies remind me of
each other because they each cost 200
million dollars and we're on streamers
essentially for free
the tomorrow war with chris pratt good
movie did you see that i did see that
okay it's months old now
but if you did not see it because a lot
of people didn't see it i think like you
pick that one up
red notice is is fine it's like worth
having on and like uh you know like
frankly you're gonna take your phone out
at some point is that is that fair i
don't i mean yeah it's not like riveting
um
but it's
like i love the rock i love ryan
reynolds i love gal gadot i thought it
was you know so like in that sense
pretty good movie it's relatively funny
it's entertaining i do like those stars
like a good entertaining family flick
generally speaking i think it's probably
rated r but it's still good i don't
think it's rated r
i don't know
i think they swear and there's some
violence um whatever that means nowadays
but it looks like zack saw the special
rated rv i saw that explicit version of
red notice i wish
will say anytime i watched it with
evelyn and any time gallagher was on
screen one of us would say god she's so
pretty yes
i was implying
which is great that your wife could just
bust that out too like you want to be
self-conscious about being like oh like
i'm going to pretend i don't notice that
she's
i i think i quote evelyn like the
prettiest woman alive she's uh yeah i'm
uh so i'm a good relationship you know
very secure you know we met a lot of
celebrities in our adventures zach but
gallagher has not has eluded us
[Laughter]
sophia bush is it sophie butcher sophia
bush sophia right yes i had a crush on
her when i was in middle school and we
met her in real life and i
kind of froze man i always thought i'd
play that cool that's so funny
i remember that day froze so zach is a
very cool guy i think people can sense
that so cool um so i you know i i don't
remember him freezing i do remember him
after the fact saying he had a childhood
crush on sofia bush and the same day
we met my rock god idol eddie vedder oh
yeah and i did not freeze you did not
freeze you're all about it
i was so cool i was just like
i was like sup eddie i wasn't like that
but i was i did say to him i was like
hey huge fan admirer and then he said
something nice to me yeah that was cool
and it did it did make my heart sing
imagine a person you rocked out to in
your
88 honda accord uh you know as a
teenager then saying what did he say to
him he said so he was leaving when i was
coming in he said oh man i'm missing the
main event oh yeah that's right that was
cool it's like when you see because we
didn't get to meet some some cool people
on the trail and and if they say
something to you that um is like
remotely positive it'd stick with you so
like my example
is we met dave chappelle the first time
and you were like hey this is my
campaign manager and i was like hey dave
great to meet you he was like oh you're
the kid bay manager you're doing a great
job and then pretty much just you know
started talking about something else but
i was like i always felt like i might
put this i want to um see if i might uh
if i'll put it on the cover of my book
like you did a great job or something of
that sort i just thought it was very
chappelle way of uh
he does just cut to the heart of things
doesn't he it was funny uh but yeah man
we we should ask him um and also a
reminder zach grauman has a book coming
out oh yeah may 24th we're gonna hype
this up
i think they wanted a breathing from
breather from uh from ford's book i
don't know or or there's actually also
there's supply chain stuff in the books
too it's actually there is a supply
chain picture that's true that my
publisher told me that stuff and so we
we had to talk about
making a warehouse full of forward books
it's like it's in connecticut it's like
out of raiders of the lost ark it houses
50 and i'm kidding that none of that
we're gonna crush audio books is what's
gonna happen um all right show wreck and
then we'll talk about more depressing
stuff um i can't wait until i'm market
pressing stuff um show rex i have three
uh two i've seen one i have but i'm
pretty pumped about continue okay
one have you seen midnight mass on
netflix it looks tremendous but i have
not it's freaky um and if anyone's grown
up religious like grew up it my mom was
catholic i didn't i grew up protestant
but it like
the way it's done is um
pretty wild it's kind of scary like it
does like kind of it's a little jumpy
you know so if you don't like that um
but it got pretty good it got it was i
was like i randomly found it like it
showed up in netflix and then i looked
up it wasn't just me thinking it was
good like it had like they got 80 or
something 80 plus percent on rotten
tomatoes the other one that this is
older but uh no one ever talks about
enough there's a show called shadow and
bone on netflix that is like a fantasy
situation and
is it good i loved it i loved it um it's
one of the guys from westworld is one of
the main characters i'm gonna look up if
they renewed it for season two really
and season one got on rotten tomatoes oh
yeah i'm not that 89 audience score so
i'm not uh losing my mind shadow and
bone on netflix very good
but the one i'm super excited about
is is the new beatles documentary coming
out did you hear about this it's called
get back so it's peter jackson the
director of lord of rings no way lord of
the rings director peter jackson has
like all this unwatched footage of from
the beatles apparently it's seven hours
it's on disney plus i believe
um
don't hold me oh it's disney plus cool i
was like don't hold me to that no you
can hold me that now um
it airs i think thanksgiving night it
airs
um
let's see when this comes out yeah it's
up on thing november 25th yeah
thanksgiving night so tonight it airs
and it could suck you know i haven't
seen it but i'm pretty optimistic so the
series that we are presently addicted to
is succession oh i haven't watched
anything new season i heard it's pretty
good i've watched the first three though
so succession is both funny and
dark at the same time
i i will say i walked into one of the
manhattan buildings that they used as a
setting for succession uh in hudson
yards yeah and then i literally just
started humming the succession themes
like plink
and i went home and told everyone about
sorry but succession is excellent and
i'm going to do a random deep cut of
movie that i watched on netflix and it
stars jamie lannister oh yeah this is
gritty
uh so you have to be in that frame of
mind it's called shot caller and it's
about a guy who winds up in jail jamie
lannister i can't say his real name it's
like nikolaj costar waldow or something
but uh jamie lannister and he he goes to
jail and then he becomes
a badass and then he comes out and it's
it's well done it's gritty it was made
by one of those pro-social movie studios
so it's like a message film but it was
and and you think to yourself there's no
way that you can convince me that jamie
lannister went to jail as like a normal
dude and and comes out like a hardened
uh criminal but the movie does a good
job with it so shot caller
deep cut on
i saw it on netflix yes it's probably
still there and uh
jamie lannister's actual name is nikolaj
koster waldow
he's danish
i'm told he's very handsome in real life
another person we never met that's not
surprising also we just saw king richard
the will smith movie
about venus and serena williams coming
up as kids and wow was that movie
really like it was a great watch you
were watching being like wow this really
happened and then you realize it did
really happen it was one of these kind
of true stranger than fiction so
inspirational
uh i you know evelyn i immediately joked
it's like why aren't we trying to turn
our kids into tennis prodigies even
though that would be a total bust
but king richard
is a great watch it's um we saw it on
streaming one of my favorite actors will
smith for sure i use
his range of like the a-listers that are
out there
his range is i don't know i can't really
say second to none i don't think he's
ever won an academy award i was looking
this up
they're saying this is going to be oscar
bate but he does a very strong job
inhabiting this character because you
kind of forget he's will smith sometimes
and then he and this the character is
three-dimensional like he's presented as
a highly imperfect human being shall we
say even though his
visions for his daughters came
true in the most spectacular fashion
imaginable yeah uh and it made me try
and remember when venus and serena
williams
made their professional debuts because i
do remember you know and i remember
venus williams being good and they say
hey fyi her little sister is better and
we were like can that be real and then
then serena comes and dominates um i i
then told um you know i mentioned
uh to evelyn that friend of the podcast
alexis ohanian is married to serena
williams so we know mr serena williams
even though we i'd like i'm friendly
with alexis but i have not met serena no
um
i loved men in black one and two
and i was obsessed with that soundtrack
for the second one which wasn't good for
the record um
do you remember the soundtrack of men in
black too
the first one was more iconic but the
second one was ninja head the black
suits come in dodge head but we'll yeah
anyway will smith used to make a song
for every movie remember that oh yeah i
mean he has four grammys this is the
thing i want he needs he's been
nominated for two academy awards and
five goals we should do a conversation
on the most singable will smith anthem
oh it has to be miami miami right bien
and bonito
got some hits man got some bangers so
those are our content recommendations
please feel free to send us yours
because clearly zach and i watch we're
limited
no we're not that bad but yeah clearly
we watch stuff
[Laughter]
we do watch stuff man
um that's how we get through
frankly some of the annoying or
depressing or sad or dark news of the
day but we do need to talk about it
because we haven't talked about it all
[Music]
all right so now that we have done the
happy thanksgiving content stuff we're
going to talk about what's been
dominating the news over the last number
of days and that is the carl rittenhouse
verdict
and it's a tough subject
anytime i think about it it just makes
me
sad and disheartened for where we are as
a country
uh i i thought that the verdict was
uh
legally appropriate but a very very
tough and uh negative message i feel
like we need a trigger warning if we're
going to talk about kyle written house
because we've been silent avoiding
twitter on this
well twitter is the wrong medium correct
my mind you know what i mean it's like
you put something out and then you have
to go
deeper into it so first let me say that
the entire thing just makes me very very
sad i think that is the appropriate
emotion where
this
young man kid i mean he was technically
a kid at the time 17
goes to the site of
a protest with an automatic weapon
uh ends up
killing two people and wounding another
and then is acquitted
and i have a tough set of emotions on it
because i think that
what we see here is someone who did
something that in my mind was
the opposite of praiseworthy was immoral
was dangerous it ended up taking
people's lives but i understand the
verdict because according to the letter
of the law
you can see why
they can argue that he was acting in
self-defense and that the state did not
meet its burden of proof
and for the folks around the country who
are saying look this verdict doesn't
send a positive message i would happen
to agree with that like i think that uh
somehow stamping that this kind of
dangerous
uh
careless reckless kind of behavior
uh that did result in people's deaths is
legal i think is a very very
uh
difficult negative message uh to be sent
out there but i understand why
he was acquitted because
i think that the self-defense
rationale was
borne out
by various pieces of evidence
people on both sides are very very very
have been very very angry about this
they're very very emotional about this
do you think
to me my opinion is at this
like a
poster child for media inflammation of
certain stories do you think the media
has a lot to blame with how
how we're literally so polarized on this
trial oh yeah i mean the media
unfortunately is now
trying to pit everything in terms of
uh this
civil war which in my opinion is more
and more likely in part because of the
media there's a bit of a self-fulfilling
prophecy going on and certainly the
lionization of kyle rittenhouse uh in
certain
quarters of the
right right leaning or
um you know fox news universe i
completely disagree with i mean like
presenting kyle rittenhouse as
a hero strikes me as very very
irresponsible
but
you know on the other side i think that
they're presenting kyle rittenhouse as
also some kind of racially motivated
white supremacist type which
you know i i don't think
is
necessarily borne out also by the fact
or should be the focus i mean the focus
should be that these two people lost
their lives a person was wounded uh and
for
kyle rittenhouse especially because in
this case
you know when when you look at it and
say well it shows that you know white
man can do no wrong
um in the united states of america i
mean his victims were white so you know
that that doesn't necessarily fit the
prevailing
type of of narrative though what it says
to me really is that our gun laws are
messed up which i think a lot of people
would agree with but according to the
laws as they're currently written i
understand the verdict
these four things can all be true at the
same time and if you live on twitter
none of them only one can be true or so
um these are the four one national media
did not cover
this case accurately particularly in the
year or so
leading up to the trial that's number
one number two that this is objectively
a tragedy that a 17 year old with an
automatic rifle feeling that he
not only needs to defend his city or be
in that that environment but that maybe
that he's entitled to do that that he
should be right um i think that's a
tragedy um the third one is that the
evidence of self-defense was
pretty to i would say very strong
actually when you look at the facts of
the case um
and then
julian castro tweeted this and i thought
was interesting is that if cal britton
house was black
we're probably having a different
conversation and there's a probably a
significantly higher chance he's in jail
um
i mean there's a higher chance that he
would have been shot on the scene if
he'd be like you know
like there is an issue where
he was walking past law enforcement with
his hands up and they were supporting
him yeah they were yeah so encouraging
him so so those things are real um but
no
i don't think that it's appropriate to
want a verdict uh to to
be in keeping with like a particular
um
message i mean it is a person it's a
court of law if the person's
uh to be acquitted on the basis of the
law i mean you have to accept that in my
view
um so it's a very tough situation it
makes me sad it makes me sad for the
families of the people who lost their
lives uh it makes me sad that our
country
um is trying to make
a cause out of what in my view is
something that a very very
you know irresponsible immature 17 year
old did like lionizing that that kid is
a hero strikes me as irresponsible on
itself
uh
no one of the the struggles that i have
very often
is that
you see something happen particularly in
this age of social media and then you
magnify it and you can look at this
incident and say oh
there's like a race war or civil war and
and that's a narrative that the media
does love and love to fuel
and i i try and remove myself at least a
couple steps and say wait like is this
like an army of people all organized or
is this just one
in this case you know 17 year old with
terrible ideas
and
you know and then the the reverse
happens in waukesha wisconsin and you
can say look is this all
people of color or black people like of
course not like we we can't
be seeing things through these
collectivized racialized lenses or else
anytime someone does something it's like
oh all people of that background
will think a certain way will act a
certain way as soon as you start to
generalize to that degree then we're
lost in my opinion like i try and look
at something and say okay this human
being made these terrible decisions
and our systems do have issues for sure
um
and i think there's a way that we can
make progress on them without succumbing
to some of like the baser
narratives
but this thing just has made me very sad
and i do
very very much dislike the message that
somehow it's appropriate to take the law
into your own hands leave the house with
a weapon like that like those things are
very negative in my view i'll talk to
carly about this and she said there's
like the macro argument and the micro
argument so on this macro like macro on
a justice level and the macro justice
level
there's a lot of people on the left
there's like well white people been in
power for a long time and they deserve
this and on a macro maybe that is if
you're trying to balance a scale maybe
that's a true statement
but on the micro level if you look at
kyle as a human in the actual cases and
that um
you know if i was watching from the
outside i was looking like
i was i felt i thought we all were
under the impression that he was
from outside of wisconsin brought his
ak-47 that he got illegally
and
was shooting down mowing down black
lives matter protesters and that he's a
white supremacist and that was like the
recurring narrative even on the right
and they were saying you know the
wright's early narrative was
this is the fault of bad government and
not the fault of the kid and they were
even depending on they weren't even you
know they're kind of giving that side
the argument to the democrats but when
you look at the facts is that he was
actually from kenosha like he lived
there his dad lived there he had a job
there
the gun was legal in the state of
wisconsin
um
and the people he shot were not black
lives matter protesters they were
actually convicted um criminals who are
who were white and not that that matters
when you talk about human life but it's
just a different narrative that's been
framed so there's macro and
micro and i think twitter doesn't know
there's no nuance for that a lot of
people don't want that nuance they
picked a team and they're they're either
happy or upset about this and it's it's
a shame i think it's a tragic yeah if
you're on team humanity or or team usa
it's just sad it's like uh you know like
the thing and it does in my view send
a message you do not want to send which
is that vigilantism uh is
somehow appropriate uh or that this
person's actions were somehow
uh
not just legal but moral or praiseworthy
yeah you know like that like though
i
happen to think that
he should not have been there certainly
with a firearm and the rest of it and
that these people's lives should not
have been lost in this way the fact that
you can get these types of weapons yeah
that's that's really good and open carry
that problem and in wisconsin it's
totally legal so but i wanted to make
sure we we haven't talked about it at
all well before frankly the trial was
going on and then what do you need to
talk about and then the verdict comes
out and then it's just like a
hyper-charged like twitter atmosphere
and then you're like well you know it's
like i would have to go on for
um
some length uh to try and express
something that isn't and and part of it
too is like i always try and be helpful
or productive and so if you're like hey
i'm just going to you know say something
to say it like you know it didn't seem
like the right approach but clearly you
know we we see this and
um
at least on my side like i just felt
very sad about it every every
you know time i've
been reflecting on it for the last
number of days
[Music]
so this article was written um that we
were reading on uh new york mag
intelligencer um what's the actual title
of it the biden squeeze joe biden's big
squeeze um but he talks about the
pressure particularly on the left
of you have like the activists and the
outrage and there's pressure coming from
there and then you have where the actual
voters are and particularly on the left
they're they're struggling and joe has
been stuck in the middle so let's talk
about this article because in a way it
kind of encapsulates kyle
and that whole trial too at least in
terms of the dynamics at play yeah so i
thought this article was fascinating and
if you haven't read it you should check
it out it's by jonathan
c-h-a-i-t in new york magazine
and it it has one turn of phrase that i
think is getting quoted a lot it talks
about joe biden as a patient who's
wasting away of some undiagnosable
disease which was a very very tough
image
and i
thought that that description
unfortunately
it reflected what what many people are
are feeling uh and the dynamics that
jonathan
chait points out are that you have this
very very inflamed
uh progressive wing of the party and one
thing he references that i know you and
z you and i talked about on the campaign
trails act was that that wing could be
summarized on the presidential
trail by elizabeth warren like elizabeth
warren took great pains to win over
those activists the intellectual
progressives that jonathan
talks about as well yeah yeah so she
went hard in that direction and she won
those
organizations like if you look at the
organizations they all endorsed her and
then when it came to the primaries the
votes weren't there
and i thought that should be a very very
stiff lesson which is that it turns out
that most mainstream democratic voters
don't actually take their cues from
these organizations and then if you try
and extrapolate that to the general
population and the relationship will be
even weaker
so yeah um but there's a lot of energy
in those quarters there's a lot of
social media energy there's a lot of
media attention a lot of journalists are
sympathetic to it and money there and
apparently there's some money so this is
one of the minor revelations of this
article is it talks about how there are
major funders major donors who are
giving to these organizations which are
dragging
the party left
and they
made this comparison i think they said
that democrats have moderate voters and
very very uh left-leaning donors and
then the republican party is the reverse
where you have moderate donors and very
very right-leaning voters
yeah so i thought that was uh
the koch brothers are strategic their
voters are bananas
um our voters our democratic voters are
moderate but our funders are crazy
so that was
i thought a
very interesting characterization of
what's going on yeah on the left
um it turns out that a lot of elements
of this legislative package are very
popular the build back better whenever
you polled them i think they had them at
58 plus most of the measures
and this is the other side of the
squeeze is that joe biden's agenda has
gotten stifled by various centrist
senators
joe manchin and kirsten cinema chiefly
among them and the argument that the
article makes is that look the fact that
there are a lot of people recoiling at
some of the leftist cultural messaging
actually does not mitigate the appeal
of some of the economic measures that
are being considered around family leave
lower drug prices
uh child care university community
college yeah like these things are
actually by and large popular
um so the the issue with democrats
unfortunately is is that their agenda is
getting stifled even though their agenda
is kind of popular by some people on one
side and then the other side is pissing
everyone off because they're making
various cultural arguments that the
majority of people don't like
and this is a
note that bill maher has been hitting
very very hard over the last several
weeks it's funny just because like i was
on his show maybe i'm sensitive to it
but then he went on
cnn and he's been really hitting this
hard his latest thing was about how if
he was the messaging czar um here's what
he would do
um and he's pointed out the tough truth
is that when you present any of this to
the democratic party certainly the
progressive wing
there is zero self-reflection or
desire to moderate the message
what they argue is that virginia was
lost not because
of anything they did but maybe terry
mcauliffe was too moderate and you
should have had
like a more diverse candidate or
something along those lines that
and because of this disconnect i think
that
it's going to be tough
that no matter what happens
i think that democrats are going to act
in a certain way
not because they necessarily even
believe it's going to maximize their
chances of victory something that
someone posed online to me and said hey
why would they do this if they're trying
to win and what i responded reflexively
without thinking about it was like they
actually don't care if they win yeah and
we're gonna be right
on the right side of history
that i guess right what was the other
goal well so this is one of the
weaknesses of a duopoly in my view and
the framing i've been using is that the
two sides play you lose i lose you lose
i lose well we all do the losing
but they don't truly lose
that for long you know it's like if they
fumble an election away then they'll
still be around this is another
disconnect
in terms of the incentives of a select
number of legislators in congress versus
the party so okay check it out let's say
i'm like a very left-leaning progressive
now if the democratic party loses the
majority then in theory i will have
uh less ability to influence legislation
so that should make me sad right now the
people that define whether the
democratic party
keeps the house are not people in super
blue areas but in really swingy areas
like in you know central pennsylvania
right the lehigh valley you know it's
like that is the race michigan
places like that if you win some races
there then you get the majority
um so the people who are the swing
districts can go to the progressives and
say hey hey like can you like help me
out like maybe either don't hit that
messages hard or you know like uh or or
do something take a couple plays off on
this one sidelines
but but the motivations of the
folks on the
progressive wing uh are not to help that
person in the swing district out because
they're getting all their energy
and emails and
fundraising appeals and donations from
people who really want them just to keep
hitting the message and so then if the
party loses and someone comes to them
and says hey you guys are losing it for
us that they'll turn around and just be
like no we're not you know and because
it turns out that their individual
incentives are different than the party
keeping a majority to me what bothers me
about the far left progressive movement
is that the word is progressive it's
supposed to drive progress and it
becomes anti-progress at a point um
there's there is value in like standing
for something and drop putting the flag
out there and saying like this is right
or wrong
but then if you can't get your goal and
you're in a zero compromise mode then
it's this all or nothing situation right
like the green new deal is my favorite
they talk about in the article which the
green new deal was supposed to be a
climate change plan that you could
theoretically get bipartisan support
that deal ends up if you read it which i
have i haven't read the entire thing
i've read by five or six summaries and a
couple of long experts i want to get
some details but it includes a call for
medicare for all affordable housing
planning student debt forgiveness and
economic security for all
who are unable or unwilling to work and
that's a quote and i don't know
like you could in those swing districts
too like it's tough enough to get one
thing done if you have to throw seven or
eight things in there at once you end up
hurting i think a lot of the moderates
or people just live in districts like
yeah i am progressive but i also have to
be you know well i alluded to my voters
or whatever so i'm aligned with a lot of
elements of like what you'd consider
like a progressive vision yeah
and what's funny is i think to use
bernie as a template i think bernie led
on economic populism yes and then he did
not necessarily
uh go in for every cultural
battle right uh and
i think that's where a lot of americans
are that's where i am for the most part
many people know that i'm into trying to
elevate people's standard of living
um and and so so this is the the weird
thing that makes it complicated zach is
that you look at it
and you know i started the forward party
and people like oh that's centrist like
i don't see it as necessarily you know
like oh we should just be doing small
things and nibbling at the edges like i
think we need very very big changes
which is what a lot of progressives say
and believe too
um i i think my issue is
like a
an inability to like switch tax or
framing is like if you're hitting a
particular point it's turning off a
certain body of voters and you look up
and be like okay what am i trying to do
in my case it's like alleviate poverty
like is this other thing helping me
alleviate poverty no then maybe i should
focus on something that's going to work
to try and advance that cause and i was
relatively single-minded around poverty
i just want to you know fight poverty
and anything that's going to help me
fight poverty um and and so that that's
like the
the issue i take is like look
um if people don't like a particular
term you're using just change terms who
cares
like that's like we called it the
freedom dividend why because like more
conservatives liked it it tested better
it's like you know it's like um you know
it's like
we just like figure out a different way
to present and frame things like
de-emphasize things that you know are
turn-offs to certain people because the
polarization that's picking up and it
says it in this article it's between
people who are educated and people who
are less educated so anything you do
that like seems like your snooty elitist
including a lot of the terminology you
use
um then you have to try and like you
know get away from that impulse uh you
know like you have to be thinking about
the random blue-collar worker used to
vote democratic in ohio and michigan and
whether they give a crap about
you know like
like a particular new term that came
into being you know x years ago it's
like and you know they're just trying to
make ends meet most of the time
[Music]
the enemy in my opinion is the folks
that are passing those anti-abortion
laws in texas we're like sending us
literally decades backwards um and
they're oh yeah those are terrible right
these are horrible um
or
you could argue mcconnell putting like
let's call it conservative justices that
are pro-life or anti-abortion on
on the supreme court if that's what
you're actually fighting for right your
enemy is usually not just like
specifically your moderate dems or the
people aren't using the right terms or
don't fully agree with your
hyper-progressive agenda you know like
they could still be an ally like the one
example they use in this article is with
of darren walker who's the head of the
ford foundation
this guy
darren walker is a black guy born at a
charity hospital in lafayette louisiana
raised by a single mom and grew up to be
one of the leaders in the united states
and learning the ford foundation which
is probably i saw him speak impressive
he's extremely impressive one of the
biggest and most influential non-profit
organizations in the country he wrote an
essay
called the defense of nuance saying
like basically talking about his
proposal um to reform or get rid of
riker's island in new york city saying
like we have to like here's what we want
to do we also have to say that
capitalism has also helped a lot of
people get out of poverty and um has
changed the world for the better like in
its in in many examples
and he got crucified
for even alluding to
i guess the word nuance frankly like
literally people holding signs outside
the ford foundation saying [ __ ] your
nuance is in the article and so now i
don't know darren walker well enough to
know how great or bad he is but my point
is he's clearly attempting to be an ally
in this fight for let's call it
progressive change
and
our own party's trying to
knock him off right like i don't um and
i think we've kind of lost i just think
we lost our way i don't know what you
think oh yeah it's tough i mean uh like
now the wrong turn of phrase trump's
decades of work you know that's why like
that that's like one of the most messed
up things about it is like
you know if darren walker spent his life
doing something positive doesn't matter
you know you said the wrong word yeah
yeah or you know framed it wrong
um and that that's something that
is a disease of this time it's like if
someone says the wrong word
uh you know maybe you could be like hey
you know i prefer a different word
choice please instead of
can we talk about it yeah or can we talk
about it but instead it's um now enough
for some people to want to usher you out
of public life which doesn't make much
sense um and this article is arguing
that a lot of the progressive
causes activists organizations are
fighting for people of color and he's
saying by the numbers you are losing
people of color oh yeah that's one of
the issues too is that you have people
who purport to speak for other people
and then it's like if you actually talk
to the black and latino working class
they're more moderate they're more
moderate they tend to be straying a
little bit from the democratic party in
like slightly higher numbers
um
as a result so you know like you you
have
um
a lot of these distortions in my mind
are born of social media do you think it
just requires a spine to say f the mob
this is the right thing to do i know
what my voters want i don't care what
twitter says i don't care if they're
going to hammer me or are the incentives
so strong to cater to the left that it's
it's a system problem too or it's
definitely both but is it is it one of
the other
officials should try and you know lead
in a way that's genuine to them and
this is one thing you got to say about
joe is joe did kind of tame the
the leftist wing during the primaries
uh yes he did and then now he's getting
accused of being too left
um
i mean that that's the point of the
article is that he's getting caught in a
vice again he's in a no-win situation
he's in a bit of a knowing situation i
feel for
him in in the administration in many
ways because you know it's like i i mean
one of the big arguments you'd have to
make here is look
um the democrats this is a high-water
mark and the high-water mark is a split
senate where kirsten cinema and joe
manchin have all the power and so you're
not gonna be able to get a lot of big
things done
what's gonna happen in 22 you're
probably going to lose the house maybe
the senate what's going to happen in 24
anyone's guess but right now you'd have
to say that it's probably trump in the
republican party
and i had a conversation this weekend
with someone that really hit home for me
in a particular way where they were
asking hey andrew
about half americans now think we're
heading towards civil war 2.0 what do
you think
and i was imagining 2024 november when
donald trump is running for president
and in my mind there are two most likely
outcomes number one he wins straight up
number two he claims he wins even though
he lost a close one
and let's say in scenario number one if
he wins straight up will there be
widespread riots on the street in blue
cities uh around the country protesting
the fact that trump is their president
again
probably i'd say definitely yes actually
yeah as soon as you think about it
you're like oh yeah they totally don't
happen
and so there will be
violence in the streets
uh in that outcome and then if trump
loses
barely
and i i will have to say like him
getting trounced seems very unlikely
because uh you know it's going to be a
nail-biter no matter what but if he
loses barely and claims victory will
there be violence in the streets
almost certainly yes
so when you fast forward you realize
that if trump runs you're probably going
to see violence in the streets
regardless of the outcome
ah it's dark andrew
um so what i'm here for happy
thanksgiving everyone i feel bad well
the ironic thing is that
this is theoretically avoidable if the
democrats particularly the far left is
actually more open to getting something
done in passing the bills that like
their popular economic proposals and
getting those done because look if biden
is able to usher that and unite the
party and actually deliver for the
american people what they're all
claiming for are both on the right and
left in many ways which is a better path
forward economically in an economy
that's actually working for human beings
um
you can see biden's approval rating
skyrocketing if you did that well well
there are they're powering their hands
they're maxing out what they can deliver
and it's certainly not the progressive
left that's holding them back right now
it is cinema and mansion yeah right now
yeah yeah yeah it it it is
um the rich don't want to get taxed
yeah so they're going to get a version
of buildback better passed
you know the big open question then will
become how much is going to be felt by
voters in a way that's going to turn
both the narrative and the electorate
around
in the face of rising inflation which
will persist for at least a while
and that that's a tough one too it's
that even if buildback better gets
passed in some version in december how
soon until americans look around and
feel great
um i had a conversation that's going to
be on the podcast pretty soon with a guy
named derek thompson yeah and we
discussed how at this point your
experience of the economy is partisan
which is a really [ __ ] up thing oh
interesting
but that if you are
uh a democrat you feel
uh like the economy is doing better
under joe
than uh if you're a republican by
some insane margin like 50 points like
87 percent of democrats like oh it's
good and 37 republicans but here's where
it gets dark okay if you flipped it
around it was the reverse
uh when trump was president right that
the republican edge was 47 percent and
there was a period when joe had won the
election and had not taken power so
clearly nothing had changed where the
thing already flipped so at this point
the way you experience the economy is
born as to how you feel about the party
in power
is this because the economy doesn't
actually reflect our well-being right
like kind of what you talked about
before when you ran present like gdp
stock market doesn't touch people's
daily lives i i think that's a lot of it
um another thing is just how polarized
and partisan the country is where if you
watch fox right now it just seems like
joe biden's like screwing up right and
left and the economies the toilet
because you we have like venezuelan
style inflation you know like they kind
of
uh exaggerate oh yeah for sure like tons
of hyperbole um and then if you and so
derek said this in the podcast though he
said that
he's seeing distortions in the in the
media on the left too where they act
like the inflation's not real oh i love
that one yeah it's not that bad we're
like oh it's pretty it's getting all
high
yeah objectively it's higher than it's
been in decades um but then some
uh left-leaning media are like no no no
this is like and and the biden
administration was guilty of this too
for months yeah of talking it down
it's a very strange time in american
life now where
uh you genuinely are experiencing
different versions of reality just based
upon what channels you're watching what
party you're in and that even includes
what you think the quote-unquote economy
is doing
[Music]
let me ask you this i think it's helpful
for
one me personally but i think most of
our listeners
what is your opinion on why we have
inflation right now and if you could
touch on
the stimulus checks and whether they had
anything to do with it or because you
were the free cash guy and one of the
biggest questions we got all the time
was what this caused massive inflation
and we did some stemi checks and now we
have inflation but i'd you know you
you've talked to us about you before
with you
before that's not there's not really a
direct correlation if you break it down
but i'm curious your thoughts on where
we're at and why we're here there are a
couple of reasons why we have the main
reason we have an inflation is that you
have more demand and supply uh just like
people want stuff there's not enough
stuff
and so that the
price are going up related supply chain
shortage yeah related you're having a
hard time with um supplies i'll give you
an example i went to buy a bike for
um
my older son
a number of months ago went to a bike
shop and they were like hey we get we
have no new bikes and i was like
interesting
and then to the extent they had any
bikes the bikes were expensive
[Laughter]
so then
so you play that out across different
categories
and so you have high inflation
now
if now the the simple relationship
people are putting out there is like oh
you've like put more money in the system
so prices went up it's like let's
imagine that we had not put more money
in the system is there a bike in that
bike shop waiting for me
no no you know
it didn't solve that problem
you know so so that so that's what's
going on in different areas of the
economy
uh and
blaming it on quote-unquote you know
printing more money
um is an oversimplification um the
argument i make is look we we printed
2.2 trillion dollars with the cares act
but it didn't go to people or families
it went to banks and airlines and
[Music]
and the pipes
uh and so you can say it's like oh stop
printing money it's causing inflation
it's like
like it's a little bit more complicated
than all that
but i will say that if you wanted to
alleviate the misery caused by inflation
putting money into people's hands would
be the way to go let's say you have some
unavoidable level of inflation because
of supply problems and like you know
it's harder to produce like certain um
livestock or whatever the heck that
issue is like the way you would ease
that would be by getting more money into
people's hands and they're making that
argument a little bit with buildback
better they're like oh it's going to
help you with child care it's going to
help you with this going to help you
with that
so it's a tough spot but you can see the
partisan communication around inflation
which by the way
you know my sense is that uh it is
serious it's painful it's at a level now
where it's hurting people who have
the least the most do you think uh
worker shortages
have are imagine they are tied to this i
mean anything that's requiring human
labor if there's a labor shortage that's
harder is that
is what how much of the factor is that
having and is that also tied to like
higher unemployment checks that people
are giving or um unemployment benefits
and things like that
i think that we made a mistake by tying
the enhanced unemployment benefits to
not working like it should have been
like hey we're going to give you the
stuff and if you get a job
fine because i talked to young people
who legitimately were like look i'm not
going to look for a job until i was out
of it yeah and so i thought that was the
problem i do think that there are other
factors involved where um a lot of the
missing jobs are in leisure and
hospitality which is just some people
um either were fed up or didn't want to
be exposed uh because they you know they
might have some health issue right i
think a lot of people are burnt out
fatigued in different ways a lot of
people are just taking a step back to
try to
figure out
what their next step should be
um
but you know it's a tough economic
picture it's just right now the
messaging it's like oh democrats printed
too much money that's why there's
inflation it's more nuanced than that
right my mom works at a retail uh
furniture store and uh
she says since covey people have just
been miserable like the it's like always
i don't ever worked in retail or
hospitality it's like it's usually tough
dealing with people on a day-to-day
basis and people can be rude and we're
just human beings in many ways but she's
at like kobe is just people are
different either nastier or there can
more on edge and i think cove is a
number on most people's mental health
and stress and financial stress or
whatever it is
but yeah that i mean that makes sense to
have that job and not get paid that much
and it sucks and it's even worse than it
was then or you could stay at home and
take
um a decent unemployment check like why
wouldn't a lot of people do that you
know it's hard well it's interesting
your mom says that man because like i i
have the sense that a lot of people are
feeling that it's one reason why
like i feel frankly some responsibility
to try and be upbeat or positive because
like people look up and
it is lousy in many ways and like i'm a
you know it's like we we talk about it
in different ways in the the pod right
uh it's a tough time hearing your mom
say that though because you hear that on
about airline passengers you hear that
about yeah different people in different
contexts where it's just like americans
are
um
a little bit worn out shall we stop here
yeah like on our last nerve a little bit
uh yeah that's true um
especially in new york where we're
always kind of shitty in general well so
i i want to reflect on this for just a
moment because this episode is going to
come out on thanksgiving day
um so
people imagine andrew yang to be very
upbeat what do they think about zach
grauman do people think you're out a
beat too i don't know
probably not as optimistic as you
i i'm in some ways packages like mr
optimism even though a lot of the [ __ ]
i've talked about is like pretty dark as
i think a lot of you know i am pretty
optimistic but i just compared to you
it's a different is you're a different
level of that um
[Laughter]
so i i i want to share with everyone uh
i'm a human being i have my struggles uh
and the rest of it
um i i talked to someone who's in the
public eye as like a journalist type and
she shared with me she's like hey it's
kind of tough sometimes when you're like
your job requires you to be
optimistic and sometimes you're not
feeling it this is i'm going to bring in
something totally random but you know
maybe people appreciate it uh i watched
a katy perry documentary a long time ago
anyone see did you see this documentary
no she's got a fascinating story though
right daughter
yeah so so
um she's married to russell brand yep
and they're splitting up so she's super
sad okay because her marriage is
breaking up and you know she's on the
road and tour
uh and it's so like the documentary is
generally pretty benign but like when
they showed this print this one scene
you're like oh no where she's like
crying and then she's looking at the
camera being like i always say you know
i'm going to put my best face on because
these are people who brought their kids
to see me and this only time they're
going to see me so like i always have to
be positive so you see her like kind of
like pasting on a happy face
even though that she's not
you know clearly like like you know
super sad and doesn't want to be there
and is like crying through her makeup
and whatnot and like puts on a happy
face for when the little girl shows up
for the one picture
so this journalist said something to me
that reminded me of that i was like whoa
like that
that's that's like i mean not to that
extreme but she was like hey when you're
in the public eye you just kind of have
to you know put it on put on the
positive face we're we're all human uh
this is not a great
time in american life i'm going to
suggest
but we still have so much to be thankful
for
you know like i'm going to be able to
spend thanksgiving with my
family and loved ones you know my mom is
with us and
uh healthy
um our future is bright if we
didn't just care about each other
uh think about the good things in our
lives i have so much to be grateful for
i have a list of things to be grateful
for on my phone and i do get down i'm
human but then i look at it and be like
oh wow you know it's like i'm so
grateful for evelyn my two boys
uh everyone who's supported us in the
yang gang um uh you zack i don't know if
i say it enough but i'm super grateful
thanks for you
and your friendship and partnership
um
there are so many people that have done
amazing things for me and the movement
over the last number of years uh and i'm
i don't know what people think about my
spirituality or or what not like i'm
someone who definitely
believes that uh you know we have roles
to play um and there have been times
when
any time you know i've been
struggling or some somewhat like
something happens where it like you know
brings your head up and you're like oh
you know so i hope people have that
experience uh hug your loved ones call
your parents hopefully you're with your
parents this holiday but have a
wonderful thanksgiving and then you know
feel free to overeat a little bit have
some dessert uh you know spend a little
bit too much money and the next day on
uh black friday look at that do all
those things like distributing like
mindset of abundance don't worry about
it it'll come back to you
no we do
uh the things that matter um i think is
what i'm most thankful for right um and
i have uh
my whole family my brother just got out
of his first house so we were the whole
family is coming to the house so we
packed thanksgiving and the bills are
playing in prime time at 8 30. they lost
this weekend was sad but they're playing
tonight if you're listening so happy
thanksgiving
go bills no offense saints fans but
we need this one happy thanksgiving get
that tryptophan
[Music]
you